from the American Museum of Natural
History in New York City and beaming out
across all of space and time this is
Startalk where science and pop culture
collide
I'm your host Neil deGrasse Tyson your
personal astrophysicist and tonight
we're featuring my interview with
world-renowned physicist and cosmologist
Stephen Hawking I picked his legendary
brain on everything from the Big Bang to
the origins of the universe so let's do
this
so my comedic co-host tonight is Matt
kirshen
you co-hosts the sciencebase podcast
likely science it's probably science we
have some mystical measure before every
time you come up with a different
version on a mic it's like their names
also joining me is my friend and
colleague theoretical physicist Janna
Levin Janna welcome your professor at
Barnard College of Columbia University
award-winning author most recently a
black hole blues and other songs from
outer space nobody says it better than
Neil do you get people asking to like to
do your voicemail messages yeah yeah yes
but it gets worse than that yeah like I
need to break up with my girlfriend but
I want it to sound good but that felt
good so Janet will be tapping your big
brain on this because you're an expert
your theoretical physicist specializing
in cosmology and I know a little
cosmology we have some overlap there not
as much as we need for this situation
okay Stephen Hawking has been called one
of our greatest minds of our generation
possibly of the century and maybe ever
he's done groundbreaking work
black holes relativity cosmology is a
the mega best-selling book a brief
history of time so 10 million copies and
it brought cosmology from the frontier
of physics in to people's living rooms
and now there was a movie uh movie in
2014 called the theory of everything
starring Eddie Redmayne and he won an
Academy Award for Best Actor so what
more can you want in a career I mean me
so Hawking currently serves as director
of research at the what's the department
department medical physics at the
University of Cambridge you work there
is that right I worked in that
department for a few years five years
and you graduated from University
Cambridge if I did just about was a
close call but I got there in the end so
have you guys ever met I saw him once
but it was at a talk he was giving and I
don't think that counts that's like
spotting an orc or a SeaWorld you know
he's gonna be there so it might
interview with him before getting deep
into physics I just wanted to get to
know him a little better as a person we
had met before but we never really hung
out like we did in this interview so
let's check out the first clip professor
Hawking thanks for agreeing to be on
Startalk and let me just start off with
the first question perhaps the most
pressing question to us all what's your
favorite food for me it's pizza actually
New York Pizza boisterous oysters little
slippery for me but that's cool
okay how about your favorite drink I
like pina coladas myself but if it's not
alcoholic I would do a milkshake
okay last question last question what's
your favorite equation I know you've got
one the ablation I discovered relating
the entropy of a black hole to the area
of its horizon s people say over for how
many people get this
their favorite equation is one they came
up that's badass what that's what I know
I think you just all got a glimpse of
what it's like to be on a date with Neil
your favorite food your favorite drink
now equation those results peer-reviewed
and check out then it becomes a
relationship so just in case and anyone
had been living under a rock Stephen
Hawking has what we called Lou Gehrig's
disease a ALS so and it's gradually
paralyzed in over the decades and right
now he communicates through twitches in
his cheek and these are read
electronically and he moves the cursor
up and down on that screen which we got
a brief glimpse up and he basically
bangs out the spelling of words and
ultimately sentences and then scientific
papers that as well yes yes so Janet
tell me about his favorite equation so
this is with this incredibly stunning
discovery that Hawking made so the
entire idea of a black hole is that
nothing can get out of it that's the
whole idea can't reflect light it can't
emit light what falls in never comes out
again when you talk about the area of a
black hole what you're really describing
is the region after which no information
can ever escape nothing so this is the
surface region right surrounding the
black holes yes so there's nothing there
it's not a surface of any material kind
it's simply a boundary that separates
what can come out and what can never
come out again and amazingly Hawking
realized is in some sense which seems
intuitive in retrospect but it was very
difficult that that's how you know it's
really genius after somebody so he can't
emit anything it certainly can't you
can't emit light or be illuminated in
any way but what he realized was that if
it absorbs stuff
it must be taking entropy out of the
other side of the boundary right entropy
being a measure of disorder or
randomness or in some sense energy and
so if it takes entropy there is a law of
thermodynamics that says entropy always
increases you know you your room gets
messy or not cleaner with
intervention so disorder always
increases and so if it's taking entropy
out of this side of the boundary it must
actually be producing its own entropy
and each time it takes something in it
gets a little bigger and has a little
more entropy so in what form is this
entropy is really the mystery then
Hawking realized the black hole must be
evaporating must actually be radiating
at a temperature like a hot object okay
so so that means a black hole is not
entirely black yeah actually from far
away if we were looking at a black hole
in a very cold background it would look
to us like the black hole was actually
emitting particle it was at a
temperature radiating yeah it was
radiating at a temperature and and that
would explain this famous equation of
hawky
so there are two major kinds of black
holes we think of in astrophysics
one of them is the end state of a high
mass star the Sun will not become a
black hole
but more massive stars can and you and
then we find black holes in the Centers
of galaxies with super duper high masses
and we call them supermassive black
holes because we tell it like it is so I
was always wondering what questions
Stephen Hawking might have for my man
Isaac Newton you know Stephen Hawking is
like as the greatest physicist of modern
times and Isaac Newton as the father of
classical physics I thought this would
make an interesting exchange if they
could do such a thing so I asked him
let's check it out
you hold the same endowed chair that
Isaac Newton did I'm just wondering if
we had some way to communicate through
time with him and tell him about what
life is like today are there any
questions any problems you might want to
hand him to solve there's a solar system
stable and what happens to a star that
cannot support itself against its own
gravity mm-hmm so you thinking if Newton
saw those questions he might give us
deeper insights into black holes I'd be
curious yeah so what he did with that
question was not what I thought he would
do with it what he did was he asked
questions of Isaac Newton at the
boundary of where Isaac Newton left off
his own studies so stuff that he already
knew the answer to right but he think
he's testin he wants to see how Isaac
would do because certain questions you
might not even know to ask hmm even if
you invented the theory yourself
Einstein didn't even think to take his
equations to get a black hole out of it
right the black hole was really
discovered by by somebody else but later
on with using his formula yeah we've
been a year wouldn't be a crushing
disappointment if Newton did come back
and just wanted to know about like
tinder like tell me more about this
dance revolution of all things you might
be curious about the tinder would not be
among all evidence shows that Isaac
Newton died a virgin
mm-hmm but he got a lot of science done
so now they're getting in on you could
revolutionize the world so Jane what
question would you have for Isaac Newton
do you think uh that's an interesting
question well um I think I would love to
hear his response to Einstein's
revelation so Newton wrote down the
stunning system of equations that
describes not only how the Apple falls
from the tree but how the moon stays in
orbit around the earth I mean that's a
huge leap to think that the connection
see connect their celestial bodies
motion and the motion of stuff here on
earth that was absolutely brilliant but
he knew that he didn't understand how
the earth was pulling on the Apple
without touching it or how or how the
earth is pulling on the moon without
touching it in action a distance and so
Einstein has this beautiful intuition
that what's actually happening is the
masses are curving space and time and
things are falling along the natural
curves I would love to hear if Newton
was satisfied with that story or if he
felt something was missing do you think
the leading question of what would
happen if a star collapses do you think
he could have landed on a black hole out
of that there's no way not without
modern physics so if we look at the
history of the discovery so it was
Einstein even when he saw the
mathematical solution for the black hole
did not believe nature would allow this
to happen as you well know and after all
it is hard to crush stuff you know you
want to crush an entire star our Sun
down to six kilometres to make a black
hole it fit in Manhattan you know yet if
earth were a black hole you would make
of the
of a plum yeah how do you do that it's
really not easy I can't crush this Cup
and so it's was sensible for Einstein to
think matter forces wouldn't allow it to
happen
well we even got a little we got a some
of our scientists on the team to work
had a case study for what happened on a
more localized situation first on a team
we do we've got scientists working
behind the scenes as well yes they they
worked out what would happen if Neil's
stardom became just too much for you to
handle
so you deactivate your Twitter account
and here's what happens and we found
according to our calculations there'll
be a vacuum of celebrity selfies in
Twitter fuse with flat earthers and
eventually the whole universe will
collapse in on itself so there is so
just be careful be aware okay thanks for
this warning okay
crack team of scientists on that yeah
don't blame me they did all the work
there's being peer reviewed as well a
very thorough on this show well you know
Hawking's his discoveries and his
personality had made him kind of like a
pop culture icon everybody knows who he
is and and and what he sounds like
and we've got some images but yeah so
this is one of his many animated
appearances on The Simpsons
here is with Sheldon in the Big Bang
Theory oh yeah I was in this scene as
well so we're we are floating his we've
got Stephen Hawking Bill Nye George
Takei and me and Futurama so professor
Hawking knows how to have some fun he
did that zero g plane thing you know
that you know that zero g thing very
aware of it I asked him about it let's
check it out
Stephen you've been in that zero-g
airplane I've always wanted to go I just
wondered what it felt like for you it
was wonderful to float weightless three
of my wheelchair I could have gone on a
non unknown hmm well one day I'll try to
do that to see what that's like one
problem for me I get nauseous and I were
to throw up
yeah you don't throw up in zero-g you
know these zero-g airplanes it's not
that they go into orbit or go into space
yeah what they do is they go on an arc
where you ascend as they of course move
forward then there's a point where
there's a precise trajectory down where
the plane is basically in freefall and
while you're in freefall you are
weightless and the fact that's how
Newton connected the free-falling Apple
to the orbiting moon so so when you're
in freefall then you can this happens
but you know it's even cool about those
zero-g planes as they can do
trajectories where they can simulate
moon gravity or Mars gravity so they
just do a shallow effort they just they
just should do it do it in a way that
they're it's not a full freefall like
they're slowly coming out of the
freefall and you can simulate any chosen
gravity you want it's very cool so
coming up more of my interview with
world-renowned physicist Stephen Hawking
when Startalk returns in New York City
we're featuring my interview with
acclaimed physicist professor Stephen
Hawking and I asked him about one of the
universe's biggest mysteries let's check
it out so Stephen everyone wants to know
what was around before the Big Bang
nothing was surround before a big Big
Bang according to Einstein's general
theory of relativity space and time
together form a space-time continuum and
were manifold which has not flat but
curved by the matter and energy in it I
adopt a Euclidian approach to quantum
gravity to describe the beginning of the
universe in this ordinary real time is
replaced by imaginary time which behaves
like a fourth direction of space in the
euclidean approach the history of the
universe and imaginary time is a four
dimensional curved surface like the
surface of the earth but with two more
dimensions him
and I proposed a no boundary condition
the boundary condition of the universe
that it has no boundary okay in order
terms the Euclidean space time there's a
closed surface without ad like the
surface of the earth one can regard
imaginary in real time as beginning at
the South Pole which is a smooth point
of space-time where the normal laws of
physics hold there is nothing south of
the South Pole so there was nothing
around before the Big Bang the boundary
condition of the universe as there is no
boundaries everyone's minds just go
clear it enabled you to meditate surety
for the first time so Jen I'm here
nodding like I'm following here look at
the end I get it like I got maybe 20% of
where you was going
so let's see if we can unpack this what
does he mean by imaginary time well
imaginary time is really it doesn't mean
made-up or invented time it literally
means you you invent a new time
parameter which is I'm gonna say it in
math terms the square root of minus 1
times the old time parameter it's just a
manner to minus 1 is the imaginary
imaginary number it doesn't mean that
it's made up or invented and it's just a
mathematical it's a most unfortunate
word for it it is we gave it it is but
it is a pretty odd it is a pretty odd
little trick to own numbers are
imaginary right there isn't you can't
see oh no no that looks like one
microphone the one represents the
microphone yeah so in this mathematical
trick you're we representing time as
though it's actually space that's
ultimately what the mathematical trick
does so that when you do this in all of
your mathematical equations you
literally couldn't tell what was time
and what was space before especially if
you relabeled them to trick yourself you
know like a little game of yeah so then
what what you're doing is you're
imagining that instead of space and time
that you're just in space but a
four-dimensional space and that allows
you to visualize certain aspects of the
space-time so what about then there
being nothing
for the South Pole right so then if time
what first we all agree
you can't go south right there's nothing
about that you just go back again so
there is no if you stay on the surface
of the earth you don't ask the question
what south of the South Pole you just
realize oh that's just an old post
question and it's all completely
compacted so they would imagine entire
space-time where as you move in time
this Euclidean time you'd actually come
looping back around again it really is a
hypothesis that is as yet
unsubstantiated Hawking made Ahad was
only a hypothesis and he's not here to
defend himself so it's time right now
for that part of the show we call cosmic
queries we took your questions about the
physics of space and time out there in
the cosmos and we've got cosmologists
jan 11 2014 and actually relates to what
we were just talking about which is if
the universe is has a shape where it is
compact and completely connected then we
could be so it's as though you walk we
leave New York City you walk around the
earth and you come back to where you
started but in this case light does it
so light leaves the Milky Way galaxy it
travels throughout the entire universe
and we're here some number of billions
of years later and we're collecting
light coming from behind us and we
realize oh we're actually looking at an
image of the Milky Way in our past that
is a completely possible scenario if the
universe has this kind of connected
property it's not actually your rear end
it's what your rear end would have been
13 billion years ago so there's every
chance that in 13 billion years time
from now they could be listening to a
distant echo of this episode of star
talk yeah I love it
you know it's Planet of the Apes you you
leave in a rocket you come to some
distant planet and you realize the
Statue of Liberty is buried in the sand
you came back to where you started mm-hm
damn you all to hell okay
yeah from John Ron from Illinois do
galaxies form around supermassive black
holes or do supermassive black holes
form in the center of crowd galaxies oh
I haven't seen the latest on that but
consider that
however massive these supermassive black
holes are the galaxy is vastly more
massive than that now you can have like
a million even a billion times the mass
of the Sun in a supermassive black hole
but the mass of the galaxy is 400
billion times that so that's just a
point of fact but at the very beginning
of the universe last I checked I think
the jury is still out on this I think
it's a really interesting astronomical
question that we're answering right now
this is how what astronomy is doing
right now and we learned with the Hubble
telescope that essentially every galaxy
has a supermassive black hole in it so
that everybody's in the party on that
okay next one Oh someone from my country
Vanessa FEMA why is the speed of light
around 300 million meters per second
that seems so random why not faster or
slower oh this is a great question is he
complaining that it's kind of a round
number or she I think it was like white
why is that such why that specific
number we have no idea where any of the
specific numbers that seem to be
constants of the universe are what they
are and so the speed of light is
actually comes out of electromagnetism
it's it actually has to do with the
strength of electricity the strength of
magnetism put together just makes this
random number so if those forces were
weaker or stronger the speed of light
would be different similarly if gravity
were weaker stronger our entire universe
would be different and there are people
who believe that we live in a multiverse
in which these numbers are different in
different manifestations of the universe
and dare I say in my latest book there's
a chapter called on earth as it is in
the heavens and it's a discussion of the
laws of physics as measured on earth and
how in fact we came to discover that
they apply across the universe and
across time itself yeah if we look back
to the early universe there's no
evidence that it's changed in our the
laws of physics has changed
so right from the moment the universe
was created the speed of light was from
the earliest measurements that we could
possibly made my last final question
from Derek Liu Duras from Oklahoma how
would a Galactic Empire keep a uniform
standard of time this is a new Neil I'm
just asked why Oh an empire it that is
all coherent right yes if you didn't
otherwise care if there's too far away
wouldn't I care yeah I'm guessing this
question is sort of all right so on
earth we have different time zones but
there's a universal time zone as well
that we use yeah what's the Galactic
version of that yeah you couldn't
because the light travel time across a
galaxy is a hundred thousand years so
there'd be no such thing as any
meaningful simultaneity of what's going
on unless your communication channels
happen through wormholes and so here's
one side of the galaxy here's the other
side of the galaxy that's a hundred
thousand light-years to cross and you
create a wormhole connecting the two and
everybody's got a wormhole and it'd be
like a wormhole Skype connection and
then your signals go through the
wormholes then you could do that all
right well you agree yeah if you can
keep the wormhole open you find a
shortcut yeah there you go got there all
right so I get on that scientist well
that's the end of cosmic queries up next
I asked professor Hawking is time travel
possible
when Startalk returns
[Applause]
we're featuring my interview with
professor Stephen Hawking world-renowned
physicist and I've got with me physicist
Michio Kaku Michio a professor at the
City College of New York New York Times
bestselling author of the physics of the
impossible one of my favorite books of
is also the physics of the future and
the future of the mind
so Michio you're kind of known for
entertaining wild ideas in science
fiction that could be based in actual
fact that that characterized you
accurately I think is compared to say
that I talk about science fact which
appears to look like science fiction
isn't even kept up oh very nice very
nice
so I had to ask professor Hawking a
classic sci-fi question all right let's
check it out so Steven will we ever have
the ability to travel backwards in time
I'm thinking not simply because if we
ever did obtain that ability we would
have met somebody by now from the future
hope that we could warp space-time so
that one could go off in a rocket and
come back in the past but I have shown
that this is not possible if energy
density is always non-negative hmm okay
maybe that's a big if all we have to do
is create negative energy density stuff
then we'll all be able to travel
backwards in time
what I've done this show a few times now
and I think this is the one where I
really do feel the dumbest like what is
non-negative energy density yeah
actually I'm not even completely sure
myself what is come on it's got your
name on it
on Star Trek is called dilithium
crystals which make warp try wormholes
and time travel possible for a physicist
it is negative matter and negative
energy things that fall up rather than
falling down now a black hole has
positive energy energy to rip the fabric
of space-time but it's unstable
it collapses back on itself you need
negative energy or matter to keep it
open
that's why hockey made a very famous
theorem showing that wormholes showing
that time machines require negative
energy to keep the black holes and
things like this from collapsing again
it is anti-gravitational repulsive and
that's what prevents the black hole from
collapsing all the way okay so how are
we gonna create negative energy negative
energy already exists if I have an
advanced civilization much more powerful
than our that our civilization today
they could make large quantities of
negative energy and perhaps go backwards
in time and become masters of the
universe you can create wormholes to go
across the galaxy I fell backwards in
time witness the Big Bang that would
then enable backwards time travel that's
right in fact Stephen Hawking himself
has shown this theorem showing that the
only way to go backwards in time is to
have negative energy then an energy
below the zero of the ordinary values so
how do you avoid getting into a hole
Monty McFly in mum situation because the
river of time Forks into two rivers into
a multiverse so when you go backwards in
time to save Abraham Lincoln from being
assassinated at the fore theater it's
someone else's Abraham Lincoln that you
just saved you cannot alter your own
past quantum mechanics says the time
itself can fission time itself could
come a multiverse of parallel universes
right he didn't walk he once come up
with I can't make backwards time travel
conjecture so that you don't have this
this Marty McFly problem chronology
protection conjecture and what does that
protect it protects the order of causal
events so that you are unable even if
even if there exists mathematically on
paper the possibility to go back in time
you can't kill your mother before you
were born because that would be
inconceivable
okay so Michio was gonna get around that
by saying time Forks that's right
according to the quantum principle time
is constantly forking so that our
universe being a bubble that expands can
actually become a multiverse like in a
soap bubble so a soap bubble bath think
of lots of bubbles
bifurcating colliding with each other
and that's the Big Bang the Big Bang is
nothing but the collision or the
fissioning of soap bubbles in a bubble
bath called the landscape of the
multiverse this is now the dominant
theory in quantum cosmology if time
travel it may not be possible unless we
have this negative energy density stuff
they'd be possible for us all the day we
harness that's right this negative
energy sector but that is sometime in
the future at a point unknown but what
is true right now is that we have space
travel even if time travel is not
available to us right now so I asked
Stephen Hawking but what is his sort of
bold vision for humanity's future beyond
Earth in the form of space let's check
it out
so Stephen you've said publicly that he
want us to be a multi-planet species and
who could argue that I'm with you there
however I have one mild rebuttal because
you defend that argument by saying
something bad could happen here on earth
an asteroid that's run away virus
rendering us all extinct and if we exist
only on one planet that's the end of the
human species I get that here's my mild
rebuttal isn't it easier to deflect an
asteroid easier to find a super serum
that will come
any deadly virus that it is to terraform
Mars and ship a billion people their
collision with an asteroid is one of the
least of the dangers we now face hmm
the last collision was 70 million years
ago nuclear war climate change and
pollution are now much greater threats
of course it would be impossible to move
the population of the earth to a new
planet but if we can establish
independent self-sustaining colonies in
space that would ensure the survival of
the human race than the event of a
disaster on earth leaving earth will
also give us a new perspective and cause
us to look outwards rather than in words
it would also unite us to face a common
challenge well so Jan are you are you
ready to go to Mars for these reasons
yeah I think isn't it still a one-way
ticket though isn't that at the moment
yeah we could get to Mars with the
technology we have now and and and the
money we have now but we can't get
people home so that's but we actually
interviewed somebody on Startalk who had
signed up for the one-way trip and it
was a little odd because you know he was
all excited about it and apparently he's
married so I said what what does your
wife say about it and he said oh she
encouraged it she's building her a
rocket she's gonna do so beat you are
you are you a big fan of colonizing on
the planet yes in fact there's gonna be
a traffic jam over Mars around 2030 Elon
Musk NASA with the SLS booster rocket
and now amazon.com I mean everyone's
jumping in the game now to create
booster rockets capable of taking us to
Mars on a two-way trip Charles is the
only one by the way that's going for
same-day delivery
only if it's Amazon so I think at a
different point
Hawking have said that civilization only
has a hundred years left on earth which
seemed a little pessimistic to me well I
I mean I don't think I worry I say this
too much I don't think we look like the
most successful species that's ever
walked the face of the earth I mean
dinosaurs were here for hundreds of
billions of years like we invented you
know industrialization sort of took over
in the past couple hundred and we're
already near threatening our own demise
so it doesn't look great for us to be
honest oh I think if we don't blow
ourselves will become what is called a
type one civilization in a hundred years
that is a planetary civilization a type
two civilization is stellar they control
the power of an entire star 2,000 years
in the future then type three
civilization is galactic they control
black holes that control the energy of
an entire galaxy now on this scale we
are type zero we get our energy from
dead plants oil and coal we don't even
rate on this scale but if we can make it
to the next 100 years here we can make
it through it we will become a type one
civilization truly planetary and that'll
be the greatest transition in the
history of the human race from segmented
nations that fight each other with
fundamentalist ideologies to a planetary
civilization that is secular scientific
multicultural and at peace if we can
make it through the next hundred years
then we make it to type one well this is
a perfect time for our game show how
we're not gonna make it through the next
hundred years
so we did a little survey of how the
world will end
okay um Neil what do you think my
money's on the zombie apocalypse Zambia
[ __ ] if it's up there okay all right
shame on you nailed Jana okay let's do
nuclear nuclear holocaust alright a
nuclear holocaust
[Music]
[Applause]
Michu
me joke I want to be the bad boy and say
that we will survive
that's humanity will struggle through it
will squeak by and we're not gonna end
ourselves oh you're wrong so so Matt
let's see over here let's see what you
missed good old-fashioned on nuclear war
I know sure that would nd well but uh
asteroid and climate change at number
one yeah yeah we agree that all of this
is bad all of this is possible well up
next I asked physicist Stephen Hawking
about the future of our minds when
Startalk returns
welcome back you start off in the
American Museum of Natural History with
featuring my interview with famed
physicist Stephen Hawking check it out
so Stephen if we ever really developed
the technology to upload your brain into
some computer providing life after death
or at least consciousness after death
would you be first to sign up for that
my body hardly works at all because I
have motor neuron disease
otherwise known as ALS so getting rid of
it would mean no loss and would spare me
discomfort being immortal a solely a
brain I proceed the future unless I was
terminated by someone slipping off the
computer or by a computer virus well I
hadn't thought about that
but if you're a computer you're
susceptible you could have copies look
you just make a backup of yourself so
meet you at the time of your book the
future of mind the scientific quest to
understand enhance and empower the mind
when will uploading our brain become a
reality well just remember if at all
digital immortality is starting now so
this is an example of what's going on
here that's right telepathy telekinesis
uploading memories recording dreams we
can quote do all of the above this is no
longer science fiction you go to the
physics laboratories and you can see how
images can be extracted from the human
brain how it's possible now that we can
upload memories in animals and record
memories from animals because physics
can now probe thoughts as they go
ricocheting through the brain is what
you're describing the same thing as
consciousness because if that's the case
then we can say it's not just our
thoughts that live forever it's our very
identity ourselves our conscious self
that lives forever well there is a
theory that says the soul the soul is
information
it's a vast amount of
information but nonetheless this
information that can be put into
holographic form such that even if you
pass away something there is is survives
but theoretically that is effectively
immortality once you reach that point
that is you living forever why not have
digital immortality wouldn't you want to
talk to you a great great great great
great grandkids who want to meet their
great great great great ancestor I the
trance what that like this gives you
this gives you movements throughout time
and throughout space so this is being
godlike well that's what we're talking
about transcending the human race
because I asked Stephen Hawking about
his thoughts on the future of religion
just just to get his sense of this
spirituality going forward let's check
it out so Stephen religion has been
around for thousands of years and it
long predates science and in spite of
the effort of modern ardent atheists
religion persists so do you have any
sense of what religion will be in the
future of civilization to answer
questions we all ask why are we here
where did we come from
nowadays science provides better and
more consistent answers but people will
always linked to religion because it
gives comfort and they do not trust or
understand science hmm yeah Stephen
Hawking is imagining that any time you
didn't understand something and ascribed
it to deity science would then fix that
for you but there's the rest of what
people use religion for this spiritual
fulfillment and the rest of this it's
not obvious that science has solutions
to that going forward don't you feel a
sort of surge of excitement and the
connection of the universe just to know
that even though we're stuck on this
silly little rock that were able to know
that much that's stunning they're deeply
look yeah it is it is deeply moving so
this whole kind of notion that that oh
it leaves you feeling cold and sterile
that there is the scientific thinking is
actually has been the opposite of my
personal experience
I think we're hardwired that way
evolution has given us a brain to be
receptive to awe to receptive to beauty
and that's why there's a god gene
because we are genetically programmed to
believe in superstition because that's
the way it has always been even today
that's way before science came along
that's not knock on wood knock on wood
the truth well coming up the one and
only Stephen Hawking offers some life
lessons for us all
next on Startalk the American Museum of
Natural History and we're featuring my
interview with legendary physicist
Stephen Hawking I wanted to hear more
about Stephen Hawking's perspective on
life and so I asked him who's his
favorite non-scientist check it out a
few years ago I would have said Nelson
Mandela
he brought a peaceful solution to a
seemingly impossible situation there is
no one of his stature today hmm
certainly not Donald Trump favorite non
yeah whatever you say yeah favorite no
wife is a scientist so that's yes she
has a PhD in mathematical physics
they're like Neal would marry a
non-scientist
[Laughter]
okay you know what I would say Vincent
van Gogh his painting the starry night
in 1889 is artwork that was given a name
not for what he drew in the foreground
or the mid-ground it was named for what
appeared in the background there's a
village he could have called a sleepy
village or cypress tree or rolling hills
but no the universe was speaking to him
more loudly than his foreground
and out of that came the title the
starry night and you look at that
painting
it's obviously not what he saw because
the real universe doesn't look like that
but you know it is what he felt he drew
what the universe felt like and I am a
fan of all the ways that artists can be
touched by not only science in general
but the universe in particular this is
my man Vincent van Gogh before we wrap
up this segment and before we wrap up
the show I have a dispatch from my good
friend Bill Nye the Science Guy and he's
gonna give us his thoughts on the big
ideas proposed by physicists like the
great Stephen Hawking check it out our
curiosity brings us to places like this
the Griffith Observatory in Los Angeles
California here we look through these
telescopes and ponder the cosmos and our
place within it and it's one thing to
think about the cosmos but it's another
thing to realize that the cosmos is
different now than when I started
talking it's changing I mean we think of
the cosmos in terms of space we think of
it in terms of time but in astrophysics
we think of it in terms of space-time I
mean moving through space seems
straightforward enough but moving
through time that's a tricky one it's
been speculated that there are yet
undescribed particles of time tiny bits
of time and if they turn out to be real
able to be discovered out there in the
cosmos so tonight go outside and have a
look there's time
back to you Neal
[Music]
so meet you I've not heard of this is
this particles of time is this real well
you can look at it as gravitons so they
are kind of to the force of gravity what
photons are to electromagnetic force
exactly a photon is a particle of light
a graviton is a particle of gravity and
when the graviton becomes big enough it
becomes a universe giving us a
multiverse of universes so what you're
saying is that what what bill might have
been talking about as particles of time
are just particles a space amount of
space time natural space and time are
wrapped together that's right oh I see
okay so in my final clip with Stephen
Hawking I asked him if he would just
share with me some parting words of
wisdom check that so the course of your
life you've had it sort of unique
perspective on science on technology
endurance if you saw some that together
and offers some insight for us any
lessons that we can take with us we must
all do the best we can then whatever
situation we breathe in never give up
never give up clearly that advice
applies to us all privileged to spend
this time with you thanks for your
thoughts and your insights and being a
source of inspiration to us all
how could you not just wonder what's
going on inside this guy's head I think
our greatest gift as a species is not
our body
we're not the fastest we're not the
strongest our body hardly distinguishes
itself in any way in the animal kingdom
our greatest sort of gift in the Tree of
Life is our mind and perhaps no one
knows that better than Stephen Hawking
and so much so that he does not take his
mind for granted enabling him to go
places that we might never even dream of
simply because he has power of mind
where he has power from no other part of
his body
so maybe it is we who are imprisoned
thinking our body matters when in fact
at the end of the day it's really all
about your thoughts all about your
dreams all about how we react to our
life experience in this world and share
it with others
that is a cosmic perspective you've been
watching Startalk and I've been your
host Neil deGrasse Tyson your personal
I want to thank meet you thanks for
being with us we'll see you next time as
always I bid you to keep looking up
you